[Musique]
une esbly leader est en poste au musée
des beaux-arts depuis à peine une
semaine
un rêve qu'elle croyait impossible quand
tu venais au musée la plupart des gens
qui me ressemblaient travailler à la
sécurité dont des matisse était
absolument pas quelque chose que qui
faisait partie de mes options
la conservatrice de 34 ans et demi à
montréal de parents d'origine haïtienne
diplômée en histoire de l'art à
l'université de york de toronto et s'est
illustré comme commissaire indépendante
critique et chercheuse 1 s'occupera de
la collection d'art contemporain
canadien parmi ses coudes car cette
oeuvre de yana sterbak c'est très
attrayant physiquement donc on est
vraiment attiré par cette heure il ya
beaucoup de textures qu'on a envie de
toucher de regarder vos propres et ce
sera exactement
ou encore ces peintures de l'artiste du
britanno-colombien réclusion lui c'est
vraiment un article souvent sur le
regard puis il faut que tu aies
reviennent mon réinventeur de ce que je
voudrais a compris c'est que les gens
reviennent qui se disent qu'est ce qui
et comment il voit aujourd'hui vendredi
après midi de printemps puis comment ils
vont le voir après est allé avoir vécu
chez des amis ou sait comment est-ce que
l'image se révèle en soit dépendant du
coup on est 2 qu'est ce qu'on fait
je trouve que c'est vraiment les
avantages de mon poste qu'il 1945 à
aujourd'hui c'est de mettre en valeur
dans un contexte muséal des artistes qui
travaillent encore aujourd'hui donc
souvent on pense à des grands maîtres à
des maîtres anciens quand on pense aux
oeuvres qui sont dans un musée mais moi
c'est de pouvoir considérer b b m récent
car en plus de veiller sur la collection
unissent b leader devra acheter de
nouvelles oeuvres et faire entrer des
artistes au musée avoir une exposition
dans une galerie par exemple c'est
d'avoir l'opportunité de montrer son
travail de montrer la recherche qu'on
fait présentement mais de l'avoir dans
un musée c'est d'avoir une preuve que la
recherche et le travail sont pertinent
dans le contexte dans lequel ils ont été
conçus et réfléchie accéder au musée un
sceau d'approbation qui fait écho à son
propre parcours de travailler dans un
contexte muséal c2c de vraiment avoir la
consécration que ma réflexion et va être
valable dans le futur aussi ici n'est
bien alexandre chartier hadj au canada
montréal
[Musique]